Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright is not allowed
to Speed Date!
If you remember an event called SCP Speed
dating, please report to Site Command immediately
for your mandatory dose of Class A Amnestic.
This event never officially took place, and
there is no public record of it.
Dr. Bright certainly did not pack the canteen
with safe-class humanoid SCPs and employees
of the Foundation, and ding a bell every five
minutes so that eligible singles could switch
tables and meet someone new.
There were no public displays of affection
on Foundation grounds, and certainly no ensuing
disastrous dates at any local Italian restaurants.
Dr. Bright is not allowed to organize a speed
dating event ever again.
Um, I mean, for the first time.
Because there has never been one.
Not here.
No sir.